hitting home run off this man
that's a tough assignment especially the
last couple seasons one of the hottest
pitchers
in the bigs in sunny gray francisco
lindor the best in all baseball
2-2 in door hit well to right
did you no question
a home run from leandor and it's one
nothing try
and see this cutter is on the inside
part of the plate
so he just did a better job of pulling
his hands in
and in this ballpark fly balls usually
don't
stick around but they do not now fronmil
reyes
gray's going to try and put him away
with the o2 and he does
zach please sack and he is coming off a
terrific start against the chicago white
side
he can't draw it up any better than that
11 strikeouts no walks
castianos he's got a 2-1 pitch coming
his way from swung on hit well
nick castellanos at the horning track
caught by mercado the police act now he
gets ahead of a quality hitter
zach pleesack strikes out the moose
runners at the corner to greg allen
second strikeout of the ball game for
sonny gray a big one
that ball gets away from barnhart
doesn't know where he's at and that
allows mercado to touch home plate
easily two-nothing cleveland so
cleveland is
spotting zach plisak a two-nothing lead
eugenio suarez
police sack oh wow brings them up suarez
does not agree with the phone
with the phone call and the strike three
goal strike two
winker
you just put pressure jesse winker
speaking of pressure from cisco indoor
he knew he knew that just like he knew
the first step was gone he knew that was
strike three
carlos santana one two from gray
swung on and missed and to inspire a
little rally here to get out of this
two-nothing hole
tucker barnhart police sack will bounce
back say
that's going to be a strike four
strikeouts
one two on reyes
strike three from sonny gray daniel
johnson behind
two oh sonny gray will you stop it
that's gross another strikeout let's see
what sort of
encore oscar mercado has for his second
inning adventure
[Applause]
we'll talk about that the next time
sunny graves back out to the mountain
by castianos the hottest hitters
baseball
[Applause]
into the kitchen of castillanos she
ducks out of the way now we're full
so remember that pitch he took off the
plate for a slider
all right now would be the time of 3-2
pitch to go back to that pitch he just
busted him up and in
right down broadway castiano's hit well
left center field it's gone
stay hot casteanos it's a 2-1 ball game
that's why i thought breaking ball would
have been the pitch casiano was one of
the best
fastball hitters in the game and
especially after getting dusted up and
in
right he's got a little chip on his
shoulder saying right now about that
fastball that just
deposited the seat three two count here
he pays it off to allen with another
strikeout
bottom of the fifth inning one two
coming to tucker barnhart
he goes fishing catches nothing but air
dh frame o reyes will come up
3-2 grounded to shore galvest with a
pick and throw
gray gets out of the sixth akiyama gets
the board for joey votto
soaked up on the back bottle 3-2 he gets
it
hunkers down because joey votto just
went up and out
a go-ahead two-run shot and it's 3-2
cincinnati
got activated today and i told you that
that choking up the back does not
cause the power outage he's so quick
once he gets his foot down we'll get a
chance to see
how quickly he gets the barrel to the
ball on an inside part of the plate
look at this foot down and he absolutely
got his hands through
barreled down launches it up
and the pitcher knows unfortunately in
this ballpark
[Applause]
giving love to the grounds crew
[Applause]
get rid of that police
strikes out galvez looking first
and second nobody out in the eighth
comes up on barnhart throw down to
second
gets him nobody that cleveland would
rather have up there
than leandora the 2-2
can make it a little easier for him if
he gets the job done
last chance for cleveland and he strikes
out johnson
iglesias slams the door the reds win 3-2
[Applause]